foreign
welcome to Simply launch YouTube channel
in this session we will understand
business analysis but before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple Technologies if
you're a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn now without further
Ado let's get started with our agenda
for today's session we will understand
what exactly is business analysis who is
a business analyst the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
the skills required to become a business
analyst the most important tools used by
business analysts on a day-to-day basis
and finally real-time training from
Simply learn but before we begin if
you're an aspiring business analyst who
is looking for online training and
certification from the experts and the
renowned universities then search no
more simply learns postgraduate program
in business analysis from Purdue
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google Microsoft should be your right
choice for more details on this course
please check out the link in the
description box below with that having
said back to our training it is no
surprise that business analytics and
business intelligence are two of the
fastest growing markets in the world
organizations today are generating data
at a rapid rate there is a need to use
this business data and make smarter
decisions
companies are looking for methods and
tools to turn business data into
actionable insights this is where
business analytics and intelligence can
help play a critical role business
analytics is the process of collecting
analyzing and drawing valuable
conclusions from vast volumes of data
available it helps to improve business
performance through fact-based decision
making on the other hand business
intelligence of bi is a technology that
enables data preparation data mining
data management and data visualization
it allows you to analyze data with
queries and create reports and
dashboards with the help of charts and
graphs to be used by Business Leaders
business analytics and business
intelligence together create
capabilities for companies to compete in
the market effectively consider this
example
suppose you sell homemade chocolates
through an online store business
intelligence provides meaningful
insights into the past and current state
of your business bi tells you that sales
of your milk chocolate have spiked up in
Texas the past two weeks so you decide
to manufacture more milk chocolates to
keep up with demand business analytics
asks why did sales of milk chocolate
Spike up in Texas by scrutinizing your
website data you learned that most
traffic has come from a post by a food
blogger based in Texas who like to make
chocolate
this Insight helps you decide to send
complimentary chocolates to a few other
well-known food bloggers throughout the
United States
using cutting-edge business analytics
and intelligence tools such as Microsoft
Excel SQL power bi and Tableau can
enhance customer experience improve
efficiency conduct competitor analysis
and accelerate growth with this basic
knowledge of business analytics and
business intelligence let's look at the
topics we'll be covering in this video
we will start with learning the need for
business analytics and the
responsibilities of a business analyst
then we will look at the top business
analytics skills and learn about
business analytics and intelligence with
Microsoft Excel after that we will see
the basics of business intelligence and
get an idea about agile and scrum
methodologies
next we will learn to create reports and
dashboards in Microsoft Excel and
understand in detail how to visualize
data with top business intelligence
tools such as power bi and Tableau let's
get started we will understand the
importance of business analysts with a
sort and interesting story
so meet Rob he runs a cafe in a small
town far away his Cafe is one of the
oldest and most popular eateries in town
Rob's Cafe was usually popular amongst
customers and it was doing very well
until the onset of the deadly
Coronavirus
due to covid-19 like other eateries Rob
was forced to shut down his Cafe too
this took a heavy toll on his business
and subsequently he lost his customers
none of his customers visited his Cafe
and this resulted in a huge loss for him
he knew he couldn't afford to close his
business forever as it would take time
for Coronavirus to be eradicated
but he was lost this situation was new
to him and he didn't know how to reopen
his business amidst this pandemic
after a lot of brainstorming he
recollected reading about business
analysts he remembered that business
analysts are professionals who enable a
change in an organization he felt like a
business analyst could help him sort out
his current business problems hence
without wasting any time he set out to
hire a business analyst he hired Ted the
business analyst to help him with his
ongoing business problems Rob entrusted
Ted with reopening the business
the first step Ted took was to have a
discussion with Rob and understand the
business problems and the objectives
that is ideally the first step a
business analyst would take on
discussion with Rob Ted learned that the
business objective was to reopen the
business and get at least 80 percent of
the customer base back in addition to
that Rob also wanted Ted to look for
sustainable ways to reopen and continue
the business in the long run amidst the
pandemic Ted studied the case and he
came up with a few suggestions that he
thought was fit for Rob's business
his first suggestion was to develop an
exclusive home delivery app for Rob's
Cafe
this way Ted knew that business will
improve as customers prefer home
delivery in the current scenario next
Ted suggested that Rob has work from
home meal boxes added to his menu
many professionals are working from home
currently and having work from home meal
boxes would be a good pick for such
Professionals in the middle of a busy
day
Ted's third suggestion was to bring down
the selling cost by providing discount
coupons that can be utilized by
customers
having a discount will enable more
customers to order from Rob's Cafe of
course it was not possible to get the
customer base back without any short of
price Cuts in the current situation
finally Ted suggested the drop staff
would facilitate home delivery orders
this way he didn't have to lay off his
stuff and at the same time get the home
delivery running so these were a few
suggestions given by Ted yes depending
on the situation business analysts can
take up different approaches so after
the suggestions were accepted by Rob for
the app that began to make sure that the
development went well by collaborating
with the IT team that became the
intermediary between the I.T team and
Rob he provided suggestions to the team
checked the app through user interface
testing and made sure that the
requirements met well
the same applied to the other business
requirements and changes as well Ted
held regular meetings to gaze the
progress and also kept Rob in the loop
and updated him with the status of the
project attending regular catch-ups
helped Rob gain an insight into the
progress and gave his feedback from time
to time Ted made sure that the entire
case was well documented by doing so he
could always refer to the documents in
the future with similar cases as well
Ted made presentations that showed Rob
the business growth after implementing
the changes and Ted always supported his
presentations with data Rob was very
impressed with Ted's business approach
such an approach not only helped Robb
reopen his business amidst the covid-19
but also helped him get 80 percent of
his customer base back Ted successfully
brought about a positive change in Rob's
business which was highly beneficial
so that is how Ted the business analyst
helped Rob make a business sustainable
this was the importance of having a
business analyst in Rob's organization
don't you think every organization
should have a business analyst well yes
depending on the business domain and the
situation the roles and responsibilities
may vary let's start off and have a look
at a day in the life of a business
analyst through a small story so meet
Angela who is working as a business
analyst in an application development
firm her firm builds applications for
clients depending on their requirements
our next character is Rob he is a
budding entrepreneur with the vision of
setting up his own e-commerce app he
plans on selling several electronic
gadgets like phones laptops cameras Etc
on his app
so what is Rob's First Step well he
approaches Angela's firm one day with
the vision of creating his e-commerce
app Angela and Rob start talking
business and Angela promises to help Rob
with his app creation she assures him
that she will look into his business
requirements and coordinate with him to
get the app running Rob is happy about
it and agrees to cooperate with Angela
regarding all the business requirements
from his end Angela as we know is the
business analyst she starts planning
drops project and without any delay she
embarks on this Project's Journey she
has a set of planned steps that will
help her fulfill Rob's requirements
but what are the steps she takes is her
approach going to be effective and quick
let's find out the answers to these
questions now up next you can learn
about Angela's approach that helps her
deliver Rob's project smoothly and
without any hassles these steps that we
are going to look at are the typical
roles and responsibilities of a business
analyst
here we will understand these rules
better with respect to Angela's and
Rob's story first and foremost Angela
understands Rob's business objectives
problems and requirements
without understanding this do you think
Angela will be able to proceed no hence
a business analyst like Angela
understands the problems related to
Rob's business and comes up with the
right solution to achieve the goals of
the business she brainstorms around what
is best suited for an e-commerce app
focusing on electronic Gadgets in The
Next Step Angela gathers all the
necessary requirements here she
understands Rob's requirements and makes
sure that they are on the same page
regarding the project and its goals both
of them together arrive at a stipulated
deadline for the project completion
she gathers relevant information based
on security of the app the payment setup
we used to login cost of the products
and style to name a few once Angela has
an in-depth understanding of Rob's
project and gathers all the necessary
requirements she starts allocating
Resources by keeping in mind the budget
of the project
here she recognizes and allocates tasks
and resources to the development team
Pas work closely with the development
team to design the solution for a
problem
Angela ensures that the development team
doesn't spend their time understanding
Rob's requirements
in this step along with the development
team she finalizes the software and
tools required to build the project
Angela doesn't rest until the project is
delivered to Rob she
usually monitors the progress and
constantly provides her feedback to the
development team with respect to the
app's layout design and other features
she gives them suggestions in order to
improve the application in The Next Step
Angela collects feedback of the
Prototype version of the app from the
users
she notes down if the Prototype is fine
or if it requires more work p is
validate if the project is running fine
with the help of use acceptance testing
they verify if the solution being worked
on is in line with the requirements and
ensure that the final product satisfies
the use expectations
Bas also assess the functional and
non-functional requirements after
collecting feedback Angela moves to one
of her most crucial duties and that is
building reports data visualization is a
key skill for any ba in order to gauge
the performance of the app and get
valuable insights from it Angela builds
reports using various data visualization
tools like Tableau power bi and click
view reports can be General reports such
as detailed reports or it can be
dashboard reports such as visualized
reports with multi-dimensional analysis
based on display of business indicators
it is not uncommon for issues to crop up
amidst this entire process hence Angela
conducts regular meetings with the
development team and drop to solve
problems quickly having these meetings
will help Rob understand the status of
the project and it will also help the
teams proceed in the right path
throughout this project phase Angela
makes sure to maintain transparency on
completion of the project Angela
documents and presents the project
findings to Rob generally business
analysts present the project outcomes to
the stakeholders and clients along with
maintenance reports Angela noted on all
the project learnings and details in a
concise manner this will help her take
better decisions in the future and these
documents will save her time while
implementing the next project now that
she has completed all her duties and
responsibilities with respect to Rob's
project she is ready to deliver the
final e-commerce application to Rob for
use Rob is rest assured that the
application developed by Angela's firm
is apt for his business and just what he
wanted Angela's streamlined approach
made it easier for the project to be
delivered within the stipulated time
period Rob is happy and I'm sure he will
come back to Angela's form for projects
in the future so those responsibilities
that we saw Angela carry out are ideally
the roles and responsibilities for any
business analyst out there
yes some may vary depending on the
company you work for and the project you
are working on if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
business analyst is a professional who
is responsible for Bridging the Gap
between I.T and business teams
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determined requirements deliver
data-driven Solutions and generate
reports to Executives and stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation and
works closely with the technology team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new Solutions
growing a career in a field with high
demand such as business analysis could
be a challenge and competition for
business analyst positions can be
intense so you should have a clear
understanding of the roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
they need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
Bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular problem
they often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team from spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what our
features need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
while Bas identify the needs Define the
features right use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-function requirements in a business
business analysts run meeting with
stakeholders and other authorities hence
discussing issues with the client
face-to-face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with Business Leaders and users
to understand how data-driven changes to
products Services software and Hardware
can improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally based right documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a project
business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills
the skills for a business analyst are
not only acquired through training but
through experience and combined with the
ability to understand situations and the
motive behind the problem so let's have
a look at the top skills to become a
successful business analyst the first
skill we have is understanding the
business objective
for a business analyst it is important
to know the goals and objectives of the
business it is advised that business
analysts should have a good knowledge of
the business operations in his or her
organization
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution business
analysts who resolve the problems that
have been identified and not avoid them
they work on individual actions and
tasks that will build towards the
achievement of the goals of the business
objectives of the business can be to
expand customer base in order to
increase sales scale up production so
that it is in line with the revenue
growth improved revenue streams through
increasing perceived product value or
increase in marketing budget according
to the revenue
business analysts should have the
Natural Curiosity and determination to
continue learning and figuring out how
things fit together
even as business analysts become
managers it is important to stay in
touch with the industry and its changes
the next important skill of business
analysts should have is analytical and
critical thinking
now there is a famous quote by Thomas
Alba Edition which says five percent of
the people think 10 percent of the
people think they think and the other 85
percent would rather die than think
business analysts are paid to think a
business analyst would be able to
analyze and interpret the client's
requirements clearly
business analysts required good focus in
order to collect and understand the
needs of the client
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
in certain situations a stakeholder may
give a requirement that's not
necessarily tied up to any business
value but rather to their own increased
convenience applying critical thinking
demands not taking all the statements of
the stakeholders for granted critical
thinking allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those that
should be given a low priority a
business analyst must be creative in
order to reach stated goals but
resources are limited and the conditions
are non-ideal
the third important skill for a business
analyst is communication and
interpersonal skills
understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession
if you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual you have to speak several
different languages while conveying the
same message
business analysts apply communication
skills at every point the use
communication and interpersonal skills
when the project is launched while
Gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final solution
listening reading and writing skills are
very critical for a business analyst
they should be capable of facilitating
meetings business analysts use verbal
and written communication to convey
ideas Concepts facts and opinions to a
variety of stakeholders non-verbal
communication skills enable the
effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact
effective listening allows the business
analyst to accurately understand
information that has been communicated
verbally
fourth in our list of skills we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
being a successful business analyst
requires working with and interacting
with many people
these people include clients Business
Leaders project team members project
stakeholders vendors private sector
Representatives industry leaders and so
forth business analysts negotiate at
every turn during the course of a
project
at the initial stage of a project
negotiation skills are used to determine
what should be included in the vision of
the project as details emerge
negotiation skills are used by all
parties involved to determine which
requests become requirements and which
requirements have higher priority
as the project progresses negotiation
skills help to determine the functional
design which fulfill the requirements
technical decisions also require
negotiation skills business analysts
also perform cost benefit analysis to
conduct an assessment of the benefits
and costs anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not
business analysts should be able to
achieve a profitable outcome for your
company while finding a solution for the
client that makes them happy
this Balancing Act demands the ability
to influence a mutual solution and
maintain professional relationship
up next we have our fifth skill that is
decision making
the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business thus it is important
for every business analyst to think from
all aspects before presenting the
decision or strategy
they must be having good problem solving
skills as well business analysts should
have an act to think out of the box and
find a solution to problems majorly a
business analyst follows five major
steps while making a decision
these steps are Define the problem
find and Define the alternative
approaches
evaluate the alternative approaches
make the decision based on these
approaches and test and finally
implement the solution
while some may argue that the technical
team is responsible for Designing the
solution the business analyst Still
Remains instrumental in ensuring that
the design confirms to the requirements
that have been approved
now that we have reached halfway through
the skills I would like to ask all our
viewers to please subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn
moving on
we have another really important
business analyst scale that is idea
about programming languages
business analysts should have a good
Hands-On programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data
knowledge of R and python is highly
beneficial
business analysts can help solve complex
Problems by writing efficient codes
both R and python have a vast collection
of libraries and packages for data
manipulation date of wrangling data
visualization and data analytics
some of these libraries are numpy pandas
deeply titir Gigi plot and matplotlib
in addition to these it is good to
understand statistical software like SAS
and SPSS using these programming
languages such as python RN SAS you can
analyze and visualize large data sets as
well as create machine learning models
for making future business predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and dashboards
a business analyst should be proficient
in using various business intelligence
tools for creating reports and
dashboards
reports created by business analysts can
be General reports such as detailed
report grouped report crosstab report
column report query report data entry
report Etc or it can be dashboard
reports such as visualize Report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators
dashboard reports are developed by
business analysts to solve business
decision making problems different from
the tabular interface of the general
report the dashboard report adopts the
canvas like operation interface
knowledge of Tableau power bi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
now the eighth skill in our list of
skills is database and SQL
business analysts often work with data
that is structured in nature hence to
store and process this data they should
have knowledge of relational databases
such as Microsoft SQL Server Oracle
database mySQL database as well as nosql
databases
also having hands-on experience with SQL
is a must for a business analyst to
access retrieve manipulate and analyze
data so they should be able to write
data definition and data manipulation
commands such as create update delete
and insert
Microsoft Excel is the ninth scale in
our list
Excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and Powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with data
business analysts use Excel to perform
various calculations budget analysis and
data analysis to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
they sort filter and create pivot tables
to summarize the data
business analysts can also create
different charts and graphs using Excel
to generate Dynamic reports related to a
business problem
business analysts can use Excel to
create Revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecasts
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analysts can list out
dates and topics in a spreadsheet
when creating a budget for a small
product they can list expense categories
in a spreadsheet update it monthly and
create a chart to show how close the
product is to budget across each
category
business analysts can calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product
they can even summarize customer Revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
and finally in the list of skills we
have documentation and presentation
you could have all the industry
experience in the world but if it's
paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all
a business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting the findings and conclusions
in front of the stakeholders and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical Concepts to
non-technical employees it is important
that a business analyst notes down all
the details that they learn from their
projects
this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems Arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems while business analysts are
generally not responsible for making
decisions regarding project Solutions
decision making skills are still
important for understanding Gathering
and presenting relevant information to
assist decision makers with selecting
the optimal solution with that we have
covered our top skills for a business
analyst if you have any questions
related to the skills that we covered
then please put it in the chat section
our team will help you solve your
queries now let me tell you how simply
learn can help you grow your career in
business analytics and help you become a
business analyst
so let me search for simply learn here
this is the simply learn website
and on the search bar let me look for
business
analyst
you can see
there are a few courses related to
business analyst so let me open these
two courses
so let's go to the first course so this
is the business analyst Masters program
now this program is endorsed education
provider is iiba
now if you look on the right we have the
different courses that will be covered
as part of this Masters program
so if there is introduction to business
analysis certified business analytics
professional you'll also learn about
agile and scrum
there's business analytics with Excel
will also get training in SQL the
Tableau training
and you'll also get to work on business
analyst Capstone projects
if I scroll down
now here are the tools that will be
covered as part of this course so this
Microsoft Excel Zera Tableau power bi
postgres SQL
then this plan box Target process
and others
here you can see the
program advisors
and if I scroll further
is the entire course content we have
these are the different courses that you
will be learning in this course
and
after you finish the course you will
receive a certificate which will look
similar to this
so please go ahead and enroll to this
course if you want to start your career
in business analytics now let me take
you to another program
we have postgraduate program in business
analysis now this is in partnership with
Purdue University and endorsed education
provider is iipa
if I scroll down you can see here the
key features of this course you'll get
Purdue postgraduate program
certification Alumni Association
membership
master classes from Purdue faculties
enrollment in simple lunch job assist
there's 170 Plus hours of Blended
learning 11 plus Hands-On projects
custom projects in three domains
if I scroll further
on the right you can see this is the
produce certification that you will
receive after finishing the course
and you will also get the certificate
received by International Institute of
business analysis that is iiba
let's scroll down
you also have the advantage for
enrolling to Simply learn job assist
program so you will get IM jobs Pro
membership for six months resume
assistance and career monitoring you'll
also have interview preparation and
career affairs
now here you can see the program details
so you will learn about an introduction
to business analysis certified business
analysis professional this is Island
scrum
business analytics with Excel Tableau
training business and list Capstone
project
and you also have the opportunity to
enroll for some electives so we have
Purdue University business analysis
Master Class
you can also enroll to a power bi course
and there's Agilent scrum Foundation
if I scroll down
here you can see the skills that will be
covered as part of this program so this
business analysis this elicitation and
collaboration requirement analysis
planning and monitoring
let me click on view more you have
strategy analysis dashboarding
wireframing test data visualization
statistical analysis using Excel SQL
database
this requirement lifecycle management
and lots more
so these are the tools that will be
covered in this course we have Microsoft
Excel Zera fogbers
plan box that's rally power bi process
SQL that's version one target process
and others
and now this is the important part
though these are the industry related
projects that you will get to work on
once you enroll to this course so the
first project is canteen ordering system
for Unilever
we also have Library management system
for Stanford University that is WhatsApp
pay and you can see the description of
these projects
mentioned below
and
you also have
Hospital management system for Mayo
Clinic
there are course advisors for this
course now they are directly related to
Purdue University
if you scroll further use the learner's
profile and how the industry trend has
been for business analysts
so please go ahead and enroll to this
program if you
really want to start your career or you
want to grow your career as a business
analyst now here is a quick roadmap that
depicts what a fresher needs to possess
to become a business analyst
first they need to have a graduation
degree in a related field then knowledge
of SQL and relational database is very
important
thirdly a fresher should have good
hands-on experience with programming
languages and that's a prerequisite
and finally they need to have good
communication skills to nail the role of
a business analyst up next we have the
roadmap that depicts what an experienced
professional needs to possess to become
a business analyst
firstly they should have good knowledge
of the domain they are currently working
in
next they should know how to write SQL
queries
an experienced professional should be
good with programming languages
in addition to that they need to have
good communication and negotiation
skills
finally they should be good at creating
interactive reports using business
intelligence tools
in addition to that having a
certification offered by International
Institute of business analysis such as
certified business analysis professional
would be highly beneficial let's now
learn the business analysis knowledge
areas
first up we have business analysis
planning and monitoring now this
knowledge area describes the tasks used
to organize and coordinate business
analysis efforts it involves planning
business analysis approach stakeholder
engagement business analysis governance
as well as Information Management then
we have elucidation and collaboration
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to prepare and conduct
elicitation activities and confirm the
results
it also includes communicating business
analysis information and stakeholder
engagement
the third knowledge area we have is
requirements life cycle management
so this knowledge area describes the
tasks that we perform in order to manage
and maintain requirements throughout
their life cycle it covers the creation
changes prioritization traceability and
governance processes
fourth in our list we have strategy
analysis
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to identify the business need
address that need and align the change
strategy within the Enterprise
you need to analyze the current state
Define the future State assess risks and
Define change strategy
then we have requirements analysis and
design definition this knowledge area
describes the tasks used to organize
requirements specify and model
requirements it also validates and
verifies information and identifies
solution options the final knowledge
area we have is solution evaluation this
knowledge area measures the solution
performance analyzes performance
measures SS solution limitations and
recommends actions to increase solution
value now let's discuss two of the most
widely used methodologies in any
business analysis process
these methods are popularly used in the
industries to ensure smooth running of
projects the first methodology we are
going to talk about is the agile
methodology
Ajay is an incremental and iterative
approach to project management and
software development it helps team
deliver value to their customers faster
and with fewer obstacles teams can
manage a project by breaking it up into
several stages and involving constant
collaboration with stakeholders along
with continuous Improvement and
iteration at every stage
so the steps involved in an agile
project development includes
planning the project in terms of
business goals budget time duration for
completing the project and resource
needed
then we have designing the solution for
the problem at hand
the third step is developing the
solution this could be a software a
website an application Etc
it's done by the development team
next we have testing the product in the
next step of the life cycle
deploying the developed product to check
if it's working fine and finally we have
reviewing the product and getting
feedback from customers clients
stakeholders Etc now in agile
methodology the entire work is broken
down into several sprints after each
Sprint we get a shippable product and
that product is reviewed by the client
or the stakeholder
the suggestions are Incorporated in the
next Sprint
here you can see we have Sprint 1 Sprint
2 and Sprint 3 and all of them have the
six steps that we discussed in the agile
methodology process now let's discuss
the scrum methodology
scrum is a subset of the agile framework
it is one of the most widely used
lightweight process Frameworks for Agile
development
you can easily collaborate develop and
deliver complex products of the highest
possible value
scrum empowers the development team and
supports working in small teams like 8
to 10 members
scrum significantly increases
productivity and reduces time
this process enables organizations to
adjust smoothly to rapidly changing
requirements and produce a product that
meets evolving business goals okay so
the concepts and practices in scrum can
be divided into three categories
first we have three rules
a product owner owns the product backlog
and writes user stories and acceptance
criteria they are responsible for
prioritizing the product backlog and
deciding the release date and the
content a product owner is the one who
is responsible for the return on
investment or Roi of the product a scrum
Master is a servant who encourages and
demands self-organization from the
development team they enable close
cooperation across all roles and
functions addresses resource issues and
Disobedience of scrum practices a
development team comprises individuals
working together to develop and deliver
the requested and committed product
increments the development team builds
the product and includes all the
expertise necessary to deliver the
potential shippable product each Sprint
the second category comprises of three
artifacts the product backlog is an
ordered list of the features and
requirements needed to complete the
project the list can include bugs or
defects that need to be resolved
features that must be added another
technical or Project work your team has
to complete before the project is over
the Sprint backlog includes only what
needs to be completed during the current
Sprint it often has greater detail and
more complete user stories than the rest
of the product backlog once created no
one can add to the Sprint backlog except
the development team the product
increment is the version of the product
that will be delivered at the end of
each Sprint while the Sprint backlog
outlines what must be completed within a
Sprint the product increment details the
outcome of all that work
the increment is a prototype or working
version of the final product expected by
the customer the final category we have
is Sprint ceremonies
there are four ceremonies in total in
Sprint planning the team meets and
decides what they need to complete in
the coming Sprint
review is a type of meeting in which the
team demonstrates what the shipped in
the Sprint
in the Sprint retrospective the team
reviews their work identifying what they
did well and what didn't go as planned
so that they can make the next print
better
daily scrum is a stand-up meeting or a
very short like 15 to 20 minutes meeting
for the team to make sure that they are
all on the same page
now let's talk about the average annual
salary of a business analyst according
to pay scale the average annual salary
of a business analyst in the United
States is 68 973 dollars while in India
a business analyst can earn nearly 6
lakh rupees per annum now talking about
the company's hiring for business
analysts we have the Indian e-commerce
payment system and financial technology
company paytm American immensely
cognizant and British Dutch
multinational Oil and Gas Company sell
we also have Cisco the search engine
giant Google and Dell finally in our
list of companies we have Ernst and
Young Global limited American
multinational computer technology
corporation Oracle and British
multinational Investment Bank and
financial services company Barclays with
that let's discuss the top business
analysis tools and software used by
business analysts we have the widely
used spreadsheet application Microsoft
Excel web-based kanban style list making
application Trello relational database
Management systems such as MySQL
Microsoft SQL server and postgres SQL
then we have bug tracking and agile
project management product Zera and
Tableau Software for data visualization
okay so let's look at a demo on business
analyst training
often times business analysts work on
structured data using Excel to prepare
reports and dashboards
they do create pivot tables and po
charts to summarize and analyze data
find Trends and insights to make
critical decisions
so in this demo we will work on a sales
data set from the United States and
analyze the total revenue total profit
the quantity sold for different
categories and subcategories of products
across various regions segments cities
Etc
now let me show you the data set first
okay so here is my data set you can see
there are nearly
9994 rows and we have
17 columns you can see this is a sales
data set and the First Column is of
order date then we have the shipment
date we have the shipment mode next we
have the customer name
that is the custom who purchased the
product we have the segment the country
name there's only United States then we
have the different cities from the US we
have the state names
and if I go to the right you can see the
categories of product
we also have the subcategories
next we have the product name
then we have our sales value now you can
assume this to be in dollars
then we have the quantity that was sold
for each product
then we have the discount column and
finally we have the profit column
so let's analyze this data set using
different charts and graphs
first let's create a pivot table to see
the sales by region and year
so here we want to see the sales of all
the years in different regions of the
United States
so for that I'll click on any cell
inside this data set
go to the insert Tab and here I have the
option to create a pivot table
I'll click on this create pivot table
option
and you can see it has selected my
entire data and here I'll choose new
worksheet that is the place where I want
to place this pivot table and let's
click on OK
so you can see it has created a new
sheet which is sheet2 and
let's drag our columns
onto the different sections in this
pivot table Fields so since I want to
know the region
and the year so let's drag the order
date first
and
let's delete
the quarter column so I'll click on
remove field
I don't want this field so I have my
ears first and then
let's drag
region column
under columns
and
we want to know the sales for all the
years in different regions so I'll drag
sales onto values
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready if you want you can go ahead and
rename this roll labels and column
labels
now
with this table ready let's create a
line chart
this will
help you analyze your data better
so what you can do is go to the insert
Tab and here and the recommended charts
you can go for line chart you can see
the line chart preview here
and click on OK
there you go how easily Excel has
created a pivot chart for US based on
this pivot table
now if you notice the lines in this
graph you can see the different regions
and here is the legend
now
if you see the yellow line which is
actually for the west region so the
sales had declined from 2014
to 2015 and then it gradually started
increasing from 2015 to 2017 onwards
and if you see the orange line or the
red line it is for the east region
the sales have been continuously
increasing you can see the trend here
similarly
if you see the central region
the sales generated was study from 2014
till 2015 then it increased in 2016 and
after 2016 it became constant
similarly you can analyze the South
Region as well
now let's see you want to know the sales
by each category of product and the
different segments so you can do that as
well let's go to our sheet 1 where we
have our data set
let me click on any cell I'll go to
insert and I'll choose pivot table
here
Let It Be new worksheet I'll click on OK
all right so since we want to know the
sales value again so let's drag sales
onto
values field and now I'll choose
category
under rows so
let's select category under rows
and then
we want to know
for each segment also
so what I can do is
I'll choose segment under columns
you can see I have my pivot table ready
so here you have the furniture office
supplies and Technology as the
categories of products and on the top
you can see consumer corporate home
office as the different segments
now let's create a
visuals out of this pivot table so I'll
go to recommended charts and
let's say this time I want to
create a bar chart now this is a
horizontal bar chart
let's click on OK
if I close this
and I bring it to here you can see this
is a nice bar chart
and Below you can see the sales values
and on the y-axis you can see the
different categories of products and in
the legend we have the segments now if
you want you can edit this chart as well
so let's delete or hide all field
buttons on the chart all right
similarly let's do this for
our line chart as well let's hide these
field buttons okay
all right
now
let's suppose you want to know which
segment meet the highest and the lowest
profits so for that you can create a
pivot table as well
so I'll click on any cell go to the
insert tab
and choose pivot table I click on OK
all right now see
we want to know the profit by each
segment
so I'll first choose profit onto values
and
let's drag
the segment column
onto rows so we have our pivot table
ready
now here if you want to know which
segment meet the highest or the lowest
profit you can sort this data so click
on any cell under sum of profit
right click and here you have the short
option
so let's do sort smallest to largest
which is in ascending order
okay so here you can see consumer
segment meet the highest amount of
profit while the home office segment
made the lowest amount of profit now
based on this pivot table you can create
a pie chart let's do that
I'll go to insert and here under
recommended charts I'll select pi
and let's click on OK
there you go
we have a nice pie chart ready
now the gray color Pi represents your
consumer segment which meet the highest
amount of profit you can also validate
it from the pivot table
while the blue segment which is actually
home office made the lowest amount of
profit now let's remove this field from
here I'll right click and select hide
all field buttons on the chart
now one thing you can do is you can edit
the chart title
here by default it has shown total we
can rename it to let's say
profit by
segment and hit enter
okay
now you can adjust the size of this and
the color of the text if you want you
can do it from here
similarly let's
add a title to our bar graph as well
so here if you see
there's an option to choose chart title
and
I'll say sales by
segment
and category
okay
similarly let's add a title to
our first line chart that we created
I'll click on the chart title and here
I'll write sales by year and region
okay
now let me go back to my
data sheet now suppose let's say you
want to know
the total units that were sold for each
subcategory of products and the shipment
mode
so here we have the shipment mode and
you want to know the total units that
were sold which is basically this column
the quantity column for its sub
categories of product you can see we
have different subcategories like
bookcases textures labels The Stables
Furnishings art phones binders Etc
so let's create a pivot table for this
I'll go to the insert tab click on pivot
table
and click on OK
all right now
since we want to know the total units
that were sold let's drag
the quantity column under values
and
I'll choose
the ship mode field under columns
and let's select
sub category under rows
so I have my pivot table ready
now based on this pivot table let's
create a line chart I'll go to the
insert tab click on recommended charts
and let's go to line chart
all right
you can see the preview here and the
Legends which show the
shipment mode Let's click on OK
I'll close this
now
first let's remove these fields I'll
right click and I'll hide all field
buttons
now if you see this one
you can add some styles to your chart
let's modify our chart a bit
let's see I'll select
yeah this one
you can see it has given dots for each
end points which means this is my first
subcategory as you can see the second
subcategory the third subcategory which
is art
then we have binders
so it's really easy to read and
understand the chart well
okay now let's add a chart title
I'll write
quantity
sold
by
sub category
and
ship mode
now you can reduce the size of the
chart title text let's keep it
10. okay
now you also have the feature to create
different kinds of maps in Excel
so suppose
you want to see the states that meet the
highest and the lowest sales in the
United States so you can create a field
map for that so first of all let's go to
our data sheet
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
create a pivot table
click on OK
all right
so since we want the
State and the country so let me first
drag country field under rows and then
I'll choose the State field under rows
now let's
drag sales under values
okay
so we have our
pivot table ready now if I sort this
data you can easily know
that California state made the highest
amount of sales now if I scroll down
below you can see
North Dakota made the lowest amount of
sales
now
let's do one thing let's remove the
grand total so you can go to the design
Tab and under Grant totals you can
select the first option you can see the
grand total has gone
and in order to create a map we need to
adjust this pivot table so I'll click on
United States
I'll right click and
I'll go to field settings
here under
layout and print
I'll click on
show item labels in Tableau format
and I'll also click on
repeat item labels you can see
it will populate United States for all
the rows if I click on OK you can see
the United States have been populated
for all the states
now let me
select this table
or before that let's remove the
subtotal from here I'll close this go to
the design tab under subtotals
I'll choose do not show subtotals okay
now let's
select the table
and I'll actually paste it somewhere
here
now with this data
I can go to the insert tab
and choose Maps let's select field map
there you go
you see we have a nice field map of the
United States
and here you can see the color scale
so it goes from light gray all the way
up to dark blue so the states that are
in dark blue let's say California made
the highest amount of sales you can also
validate it from the pivot table
similarly the lighter the color
the amount of sales were less for that
state
now let's give a chart Title Here
I'll
give a chart title as
sales by
States
and let's remove this Legend
now you can format this map so here you
can change colors and
let's see if I choose this one you can
see the color has changed
and you can see the California state
is shaded in dark which means it meet
the highest amount of sales
you can also
add data labels you can see it will show
the
sales values for each of the states
and if you want you can keep the legend
as well I'll just remove these two
all right
now similarly you can also create a
field map to see the profits by each
state so you can analyze which states
meet the highest amount of profit and
the state that made the lowest amount of
profit so let's do that
I'll go to my data sheet
I'll
click on insert and select pivot table
let's click on OK
now first and foremost let's drag
country under rows and then I'll choose
State under rows
next
let's drag
The Profit column under values
so I have my
pivot table ready
let's go to the design Tab and remove
the subtotals
I'll select do not show subtotals if I
scroll down
okay I have my grand total now so let's
go to the design tab under Grand totals
we'll remove it
okay now let's just populate the United
States which is the country name for all
the rows
I'll right click on United States go to
field settings
click on layout and print I'll choose
select item labels in tabular form and
select repeat item labels let's click on
OK
so I have my country name populated
throughout
let's
select the pivot table
I'll paste it somewhere here
and now let's go to the insert tab
I'll choose map let's select field map
there you go
now we have the
profits for each of the states
let's first delete this
and edit our chart title
which is
profit by
States
okay
let's close this
let's say
we'll use this one now
okay
let's edit the color of the chart title
I'll make it as white
and let's say
will
choose the color
as
set this one okay now let me go ahead
and remove the
Legend here
and just delete it all right
so we have our
field map ready which shows profit by
each state
now that we are done with our analysis
and creating our different pivot tables
and pivot charts let's build the final
dashboard
so let's create a new sheet here
okay
the first thing I need to do is I'll go
to the view Tab and I'll remove the grid
lines all right now let's go to the
insert Tab and here we have
text
let me choose text box
let's create a text box here
okay
now you can reduce the size actually
let's reduce it
okay
and you can move it to the top
all right let's pull this a little down
and this little right
let's fill the text box color with
blue color
and
let's give the text as
seals
dashboard
and we'll
give a white color to the text and I'll
select my font
you can select any font you want
so I'll go with
let's say
Britannic bold
okay we have it here
and let's increase the size to 30
and we'll Center align it all right
now the next step is to
bring all our pivot charts
to this dashboard sheet so I'll first
copy my
pivot chart
and I'll paste it in sheet date let's
paste it here
and we can reduce the size
okay
now similarly let's do it for the
other charts as well I'll copy this and
let's paste it somewhere here
okay
now let me just reduce the size
and if you want you can reduce the
chart title font size as well let's make
it 11 okay and let's drag this a bit
all right
now let's
copy the pie chart
and let me paste it here
let's reduce the size of this pie chart
okay
see we have our pie chart here
now
let me
take my line chart which shows the
quantity sold by
different sub categories of product I'll
copy it
and let me paste it
somewhere here
I'll close this
we need to reduce the size so that we
can fit in our other charts as well
okay let me reduce a bit more
all right now we are left with the two
maps that we created let's copy this and
let's paste it
here
I'll go to the right
let's reduce the size
similarly we'll do it for
sales by
profit map as well
let's copy this
and
paste it onto our dashboard
let's reduce the size first
and let's increase it
towards the bottom
so we have our
dashboard ready you can see the
different
pivot charts that we created
now let's add slicers and timelines to
this dashboard so that we can filter our
tables and the charts so I'll
click on this first chart which is our
line chart I'll go to the insert tab
here you can see under filters we have
slicers and timeline
first let me click on timeline and here
I'll choose my order date column
let me click on OK
all right let's drag this a bit here on
to the right
and I'll show you how you can use this
lists
first choose
years instead of months
and let me reduce the size a bit
okay
now another thing to do here is let me
right click
and I'll go to report connections here
I'll select
all my Pivot tables instead of just one
so that
any manipulation you do
in the order year it will reflect for
all the
tables or the charts we have on the
dashboard I click on OK
now that we have seen how to add a
timeline
I'll reduce this a bit
let's now add a few slicers
let's click on any of the charts
and glue to insert click on slicer
now let's add a region slicer I'll click
on OK
and let's take it to the right
we'll reduce the size of this region
slicer slices are nothing but filters
which have advanced filtering options
and
we can add
one more
filter
or a slicer let's say
we want to do this time on
the segment
so I'll go to slicer
I'll choose segment here and click on OK
so you can see I have my segment slicer
here let me just reduce the size
and
let's drag it here
at the bottom
all right
okay
now if you want to know the sales and
profit
for a particular year so you can choose
that particular year here on the
timeline suppose I want to know
the sales only for 2014 and 2015 so the
way to do is you can select one of the
years so I'll click on 2014
and now I'll drag this
to select 2015 as well
if I go to left
the figures that you see only reflect
the sales and the profit for 2014 and
15. similarly
if you Mark here
or let me just bring it
to the middle
suppose say I want to
have 2016 year included as well I can
just drag it to the right you can see
the charts will change
I'll just
remove the filter and place it here
similarly if you want to see the sales
and profit for
a particular region
you can do that too
for example let me just bring this
region slicer here
and let's say you want to know the sales
and profit only for the east region
you see here it shows only for the east
region
and suppose you want to see for east and
west region also
you can see it changes here
okay
let me just cancel this
now you might be wondering when we
selected the different regions only the
pie chart changed but the rest of the
charts were
the same now the reason was we did not
apply this slicer to all the pivot
tables so let me right click and go to
report connections
here I'll choose
the remaining pivot tables as well
I click on OK all right now let me just
bring this to the middle
and let's say we want to know the
seals and the profits and the quantity
sold for let's say south region
if I select this you can see it shows
only for the south region let's see you
also want to know for the central region
now we have selected both Central and
South you can see the variations in the
graph
and we cancel this
similarly we have or another slicer
which is the sediment
I'll populate the slicer for
all the other pivot tables
let me choose all of them
and click on OK
I'll bring this
to the middle so that you can see the
variations in the graph let's say I want
to know the seals the unit sold and the
profit for home office segment so I'll
only select home office
you can see the variations here now the
slicers actually don't work for the maps
so you can't see any change here
now suppose you want to know for the
corporate segment you can select
corporate or if you want to select for
multiple segments you can do that as
well
just cancel this
and let me place it here
all right now we are done with our demo
so if you want to get a copy of the data
set and the demo file that we are using
here in this video you can put your
email IDs in the comment section our
team will send you the files over email
now with that we have come to an end of
this session on business analysis if you
have any queries regarding any of the
topics covered in this session or should
you feel you need the resources used in
this session like the data set the code
segments and any of the ppts then do let
us know in the comment section below and
our team of experts should be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here